The joe rogan experience.
You know,
I've fouling when I go to pitch ain't,
I'll go to pitch and idea
about a new show or something.
Right.
And they're all,
and like this one guys is like,
that's a horrible idea.
Don't ever tell anyone that idea again.
That's always the best idea I've found.
Like if an executive session sucks,
goats go digital and do it
because it'll fucking kid.
Yeah.
Once I pitched over the phone
and the guy actually like said,
you're kidding,
right?
You did.
Did you waste my time with this?
And I was like,
wow.
All right.
I guess she didn't like my idea.
I pitched over the phone,
he was like,
I go,
I have this idea for a show.
It's just a silly idea,
but it's like,
it's a comedy and it's about these girls
that work at a bikini pizza place in
the day called pizza sluts and at
night they fight crime and they're,
they're,
they're super hot chicks that are
recruited by the police force and,
and trained to infiltrate into areas
where other cops could never get checked.
Cause people would never believe that
these hot girls were actually secret agent
slats were actually secret agents.
Yeah.
Why did they have to work at the pizza
place and then a full time job though?
Well because they got to have a cover
part of the cover and then get to see them
in their underwear is the smart
county and fucking dude was mad at me.
This is chuck.
He pitched it.
The dude was mad as a
long time ago by the way.
And the dude was mad at me.
I was like,
I think that would be a silly show.
Like you don't think there could be
like a ton of jokes and shit like that.
You'd get 2 million viewers
completely over the top.
Have you ever pitched something
just to fuck with somebody?
No.
Have you waste time?
If you do?
Sometimes,
yeah.
Yeah.
This is not at first this was,
I took,
I mean like I,
I make my money helping people.
Right.
And I make my,
my real money is made on speeches.
Like I go to do motivational
speeches at colleges,
teaching kids to get their shit
together and stop being busy.
It's up to stop being
a whiny little bitch,
right speech.
It's just this entitlement by college.
Kids in college is really like me coming
and I do about an hour speech and then
a half hour Q and a and
then I'll do a live podcast.
It's great.
I mean for me that's amazing money.
It changes our family's life,
right?
So now it's like if I can do TV,
great.
If I don't that's fine too.
I'd like to do it,
but like I'll have an idea.
I mean I had an idea of hoarder road trip.
I just wanted to take a bunch
of hoarders and I went to Vega.
Take them cross country.
You make him clean up
someone else's house.
Oh,
that's a good idea.
I think it'd be fascinating to see.
I like that cross country.
Right?
At first it was a joke,
but then the more I started
pitching and I was like,
actually I like to actually take this.
But the first time I was just trying to
piss off the executive cause he had sat
on my pilot for a year and
so I was just mad at him.
He sat on the pilot.
I do,
I've done two pilots and I didn't realize
this is everyone's done 10 pilots.
It is what it is.
Don't worry about it.
I was devastated because my
first pilot didn't make show.
Really?
Yeah.
I was devastated.
Devastated.
I was like,
this is gonna.
I mean I,
I really,
I put all my eggs in that basket and
I was just emotionally and I was like,
this is so important that I get to show
and by the time the network and the
production company and
they got done with it.
It was a shitty show and
I didn't want to do it.
And I was like praying that
it wouldn't get to pick it up.
But then when it didn't get picked up,
I got all upset and I got,
I got personal with it.
And I just,
I've learned now it is what it is.
It's just business.
It's,
it's really hard to be on a show and watch
it fall apart because too many people
have their input and they fuck with you.
I had no input.
Yeah.
You know,
and it was like,
my name's on that.
It's my company's name is on it.
Then it doesn't,
and it,
I mean,
well,
executive always think they always think
that they have a way to tweak it and to
make it better.
Yeah.
I'm not saying I'm brilliant or anything.
I was just,
I was personally upset.
I think that,
you know,
the,
the collaborative effort,
like a real true creative,
collaborative effort only works with
people who respect each other creatively.
Like people will actually approve and
to be creative in order to bring someone
like an executive and
to a creative meeting.
Like what are you a creative
person who do you write a lot?
I mean,
you're going to have good ideas or is
this like an ego bullshit thing here and
your greasy fingerprints on this and
add your little ingredients to the soup.
That's what a lot of it is.
But I mean,
I'm by with hoarders,
there's no writing.
I mean,
we turned the cameras on and shit happens.
Yeah.
And that's it.
It's your show.
No,
I don't,
I'm just talent on that.
How many different dudes
are Horter cleaners?
We've got,
well,
there's two really loud,
I mean there's a lot of
people that that try to do it,
but it's like a hit show,
right?
Oh,
do doing really well.
You know,
I say I'm the number one
trash man in the country in a,
and he has no problem with you doing
all your other stuff or they just don't
know.
Sign me to con I don't even on a contract,
you're not on a contract and week to week.
Whoa.
That's crazy.
That's got to be annoying.
And the number one guy on,
you know,
their number two show.
It amazes me.
I'm fine.
I don't want a contract now.
Like it doesn't contract.
I couldn't come do this.
Like I'm,
you said it best the
other day on your podcast.
You Go,
I'm doing what I should be doing.
You're doing it right now.
And I'm there,
man.
My Pi Pica,
I'm doing,
I wrote a book,
had a great run with my book.
I'm helping a lot of
families with my book.
It's called secret lives of hoarders.
So you're just happy to keep moving
work direction and keep working.
I clean up shit for 12 bucks an hour.
I'm happy to be working,
period.
Like I'm lucky to have work.
I,
I can afford all my groceries and
my mortgage in the same month.
I'm lucky.
Like that's awesome.
Yeah.